- Okay, bad legal take alert,
this time from famed director,
Rob Reiner who writes,
"Fox News' is spreading of disinformation
"and lies about vaccines
are causing people to die.
"Legal experts must find
someone with standing
"to file a lawsuit."
Well, a couple issues here.
Yeah, standing would
probably be an issue here,
but the bigger problem
is that there's no claim
that you can make.
You can find someone with standing,
but you're not gonna be able
to make a claim against them
because of that thing
called the First Amendment.
You might disagree with the
things that people are saying,
but under the First Amendment,
you're allowed to lie
as long as you're not defaming
an individual specifically.
And a lot of these
things are gonna go down
as just their opinions
so you might disagree
with someone's opinion.
But again, that's why the
First Amendment exists
so that we have a marketplace of ideas.
So sorry, Rob,
your movies are great, but
your legal takes are not.